you all good at a lot of things this
annoying you're so you're so n you're
good you have one floor please
uh God damn it this is the cool dad by
Way's what's your what's your biggest
biggest floor what's your biggest floor
uh biggest
FL well I I realized the other day I'm
not I'm not actually a good
person okay all right okay elaborate
elaborate well cuz if I'm doing
something nice for other people for
normal people I imagine it's just like
oh of course for me it's like it hurts
me what
you like okay if I'm driving oh actually
we had this conversation yeah if I'm
driving and I have to let someone go I'm
like God [__] damn you for letting
have making me do this cuz he was he he
was in the wrong lane right yeah
completely the wrong lane and everyone
was lining up in the right lane which we
needed to be in and and I was like yeah
just you know go in so someone will let
you in and then 2 minutes later there
was the opposite situation happened we
were in we were in the right kept egging
me on for the record no no no and
someone else was kinding to join our
lane and I was like you should just let
let them in because we just someone else
just let us in and he's like I don't
want
to I was like I was like you're a piece
of [__] you did yeah because I pressured
you because I made you feel bad about it
I do it but I no one was in the car with
you you would be like I think about all
those times where I'm driving and I have
to make this exit and I'm and some Saint
lets me in the lane he's like fine is me
cuz I do it me to do it no I don't want
to if I ever see you drive I don't want
you to let me in I know you don't want
to do it I I'll wait for the next call I
think it actually makes me a better
person because it's harder for me to do
it so if anything think I'm better than
a good person so why do you do it then
if you don't want to do it cuz I Society
Society societal press I would say
Society is working as intended then cuz
you feel you feel shame for not
[__] makes me godam it so you okay so
let me get this straight let me get this
straight you're sitting there you know
be be just F be the only one judging me
come on no no no no beond just gone to
bed beond just gone to bed you finally
get an hour to think you have met you
you know you finally get to relax and
think you think man yeah I didn't let
that car in I'm a bad [__] no I don't
I don't let it
linger I don't care no you're definitely
not the only one but you're probably the
first to admit that Society has grounded
you
well I I think it's it's I think you
know sometimes you do this thing where
okay I think you're genuinely nice a lot
of the times but there sometimes where
you're like I should be nice here and
you've decided to be nicer and that's a
conscious thought that you've made you
didn't think about it and then you
didn't just compulsively do it you're
like have the options which is way nicer
cuz you're making you're making an
effort but then I feel like sometimes
I'm like man I might acting nice is that
who I really am but I but I I still
chose to do the nice thing or perceive
nice
this is too deep for me I just want
think that I'm good but it [__] me out
it [__] me out actually sit there and
I'm like am I bad person that I didn't
immediately think to do I
think but it's Al like sometimes you
just sometimes you just also in like the
mood to do something nice I gu sometimes
you're just in a happy mood and should
doing something nice always be mood
depend yeah that's a good point that's a
good point that's a good point do you
guys drive here uh Fair often I don't
know he doesn't have a license I've
already driven like I I have a license
but I don't drive too often because what
you going to say well I the reason I
realize is because of the blinking that
people do they do use the hazard lights
as a thank you oh yeah yeah and I asked
Conor do you count the blinks that they
give you cuz in my head I thought this
was like a system that everyone
developed this dude made up an entire
kindness system people do it I'm not
crazy expl explain explain expl so
basically what so basically what Felix
is saying is if someone I don't like
what this Fu making me if Felix lets
someone in and then they go into the
lane front of them and they click theard
lights
toink they sitting there being like they
only blinked once yes absolutely only
blinks once slap in the face I was like
what are you talking about I blink once
with the so people use the hazard lights
in the car to to say thank you right and
I say I press it once cuz I don't want
people to think that's a [__] Hazard
just press it once no one do this it
once yes they do on highways on highways
they do you do you do it once as like a
thank you and that's they should be they
should be that's that's any more than
that you're going to be like oh they're
actually in trouble listen here's how it
works three blings is like oh dude thank
you so much no that's four is way too
much is way an accident I do really nice
things sometimes I expect the just leave
it on why why turn it off just say thank
you the entire car ride one it's like
[__] off that
was no BL is [__] off no one does it one
that only Connor does it I never no that
is not true it's the American tipping
system right now yes it is I you gave
one blink how bad was my service well I
I guess I'm just that nice driving then
because I never get it one how many
times do you do it all the time well
like how long how many blinks well three
is like I said thank you so much two is
like all right thank you appreciate it
so it depends never heard this this is
why you don't let people through cuz
they only blink to you once so you think
they're ungrateful
exactly like no one's ever grateful
enough we're saying that the amount of
you know when you do the hazard light
say thank you it doesn't matter how many
blinks you leave it on for it matters
does that mean how many thank yous
you're giving yes it is that's that's
why I leave it at least three
yes let's
go at least three crazy no I'm Googling
this because after because three and
more is there's a fine line between oh
my God I appreciate this so much and
help me I was driving I'm so glad you're
here so here if someone does two to me
I'd be pissed yes that's right that's
right no and what would one be one is
just disrespectful I would get that's it
that's
it what are you talking about one is the
same as like getting flipped off okay
Reddit is saying twice I've never I've
never heard of this in between
everything doesn't know a [__] all this
is like a language that some people have
made for themselves and no one else has
follow like you guys have made up this
language I'm learn this because this is
this isn't in any like D the thank you
yeah the thank you I think it's like a
it's like a virus it spreads like you
just see a guy do it you're like oh that
makes sense I'll do that next time
someone that's how I learned they do
that in the UK and I was like Dad why
are you do putting the hazard lights on
and he was like oh I'm just saying thank
you son that's the most annoying [__] in
UK cuz it's always dark and then they
hazard light you're like [__] I
didn't need that yeah that's why we
already blink
once you know just show real kindness I
just get out of my car and thank them I
use the the the front light
yeah to get someone's attention that's
what I mean not the hazard lights you
use the hazard lights in UK I used I
used the front lights to get someone's
attention yeah they like they say thank
you and UK with it yeah you can do that
too yeah awes especially on like country
no like cuz like what if someone let you
in then you say you Flink because you
can't they can't see your hazard light
so you you flick the front ones to say
yeah but they blind you I don't like it
that's a that's a dumb thing I you drive
a Tesla it drives the car okay I you
don't drive the car it's reasons like
this that I like every time I go to a
new country I'm [__] [__] my
pants about what the rules are cuz every
rule is different okay so okay say
you're like in Japan super respectful
driving rules you have to bow after you
have to stop the car and
bow so so
this so this is something I learned when
I was like moved to Thailand so you're
at a junction right yeah and there's a
car coming and he blinks twice using
front lights what does that mean he's
letting you go he saying go ahead so in
Thailand if you see that that means do
not [__] go cuz I am not going to
slow
down psychotic behav my brakes are
broken that should that should not be a
signal for that you shouldn't be allowed
to communicate that no that Mak be
perfect no cuz he this [__]
would be going driving the highway
[__] flicking it the entire time you
H me on when I drive no I'm super nice
driver no okay the only time I a him on
is there was a long line and it just
take advantage take advantage of the
Japanese kindness that's what he told me
the line the line was literally it was
like an hour long and I was like we
could do listen we're on a tight
schedule here drive to the front and
merge and cut in be a dick right you
devil on my shoulder he did and we got
and we got through right away it's a
huge dick move don't do this but we were
in such a rush so yeah yeah yeah but no
feel would be like that's a great idea
and I shouldn't have told him he he
wanted someone to just acknowledge Him
and say it to him now I'm the good
person you
know like Conor are you sure are you
sure Conor yes I'm sure Felix well jeez
I guess Connor skip like a 100 cars cut
right in before the turn
off yeah that's a that's an awle thing
to do don't do that unless he also
doesn't tip in Japan what a damn
joke